think about another concept what does
the Gospel of John and the letters of
John tell you God is most fundamentally
right that is a notion of God notion not
only of God but of absolute being that
you can't find it any philosopher prior
to the coming of Christianity now you
could ask yourself well they could have
figured that out on their own
couldn't they well for some of the cases
maybe other cases perhaps not maybe they
could have figured out that God was well
could they have figured out something
like human beings were caught in a
situation not entirely of their own
making which screwed up their intellects
and screwed up their wills so thoroughly
that they couldn't even figure out how
to get out of that situation even if
they could figure it out they wouldn't
be able to get themselves out of it
that's what we call original sin what
philosophy have figured that out on its
own let's say it did could philosophy
have figured out that well somebody
would have to come along to fix this and
that somebody would have to be God and
man
st. Anselm comes kind of close to saying
yeah you could have a rational deduction
of this but not too many philosophers
follow it does the matter of fact Anselm
is is starting from faith that he's a
christian philosopher so Joseph says
yeah look you can look at history and
you can find cases where Christianity
has in fact contributed to philosophy
now how can that take place here's where
it gets really interesting
just faith by itself exists let's say we
don't mean just in the sense of a bunch
of words put together that we call the
you know the Nicene Creed which would be
our articles of faith or the Athanasian
Creed or the belief we're just belief
exists very good
well the reason this reason exists on
its own put God out of the picture
because we have an ability tossin right
does it exist on its own apart from
human beings human subjects
faith and reason are things that exist
within human persons and Jill song has a
really beautiful pastor to refer to he
talks about he says philosophy and
Christianity are concepts and that they
are connected together integrally in in
a human being so he says if there was a
faith and a reason in us whose being was
radically distinct from that of a
thinking substance to which they belong
we could name we could not say of any
one of us that they were have actually a
human being a single human being it's
not that we have parts of us it's not
like the faith part is something
completely separate from the reason part
they're United in the actual human being
living human breathing subject who lives
in history has relationships with people
develops over time no one no single one
of us is completely rational though one
of us comprises everything that you know
fall under the term of faith so he asks
actually at one point he says I would
like somebody to show me this this
abstraction a human being in which these
things would be completely cut off from
each other he's issuing a challenge that
can't be left to the Christian
philosopher unless they're deliberately
compartmentalizing because their culture
has told them to do so their faith in
their reason are going to be tied
together there's some dangerous right
substituting faith for a reason when we
actually should be reasoning
substituting reason for faith when we
should actually have faith as well joso
has an explanation here how this is
possible
now let's think about another guy
Jacques more attentive more attend
thinks that his view on Christian
philosophy isn't just in line with
visual songs and more attend talks about
the distinction between what we could
call work some talks about the
distinction between philosophy we can
come up with definitions right one
definition might be something like it's
the highest effort of the natural human
reason well it's the discipline that the
biggest subjects and does so on the
basis of natural reason those articles
are arguable definitions of philosophy
that's the essence or the nature of
philosophy for the moment time doesn't
it actually exist by itself
we have all sorts of abstract things as
we can think of think of a perfect
reason put God out of the picture see
the perfect reason ur-rahman
are any of us the perfect reason er do
we do concretely existing things
actually match up with the the perfect
ideal of them no this is an abstraction
doesn't mean that doesn't have any any
existence you know abstractions are
abstractions of some sort of reality
how does philosophy actually exist it
exists in concrete historical states so
philosophy has it's done here the United
States in the early 21st century is not
precisely the same thing as philosophy
done in France in 1704 waspy as it's
done by Dominican friars in the
University of Paris in 1212
lost on that so philosophy gets done in
in different concrete states it also
depends on the person yeah if you don't
have to philosopher is you don't have
philosophy
same thing those are theology does
theology that can you come up with a
nice definition of theology probably
have something right if you guys what
are some definitions theology is one so
they've got a that's very broad good
inclusive one lot gets covered in there
anything more precise Thomas Aquinas
actually said it's talking about God all
right that this just as broad certain
well today anything else the individual
theologians at you you studied and you
guys let's the alone you actually exist
right if all those books of theology
there's worldwide capitalism and once
let's imagine some sort of book eating
virus but getting bacteria it's all the
books available the whole internet goes
down now you guys are doesn't leak one
one right now you guys are completely on
your own resources you have to restart
theology all over again wouldn't you
let's say you forgot most of what you do
from classes
theology would be in a different
concrete state if you guys went around
and nobody else was doing it no more
theology it everybody exists potentially
as an idea as an abstract essence it
wouldn't exist in reality
something condition so now philosophy if
it's done in a Christian environment is
going to be
done in a different way than it is in a
pagan environment there's gonna be
certain things that Christianity affords
access to like God is law right the
pagan philosopher might come across the
idea that God is love what are they
going to ruminate on it are they going
to get a lot of mileage out of it are
they going to write whole books about it
probably not Christian philosophers have
say that's what was both and so if you
think about it the history of philosophy
should be filled with examples according
to Jeff saw morgantown cases where
Christianity has come through and faith
and reason have been of a fruitful
dialectic with each other not as sort of
things off on their own but in human
persons who had to make sense of their
experiences at the time that they were
writing again they understood that very
rigid distinction between philosophy and
theology and philosophers did not have
been doing theology does what we've been
talking about so far with Jill some more
time does that sound all like what you
guys are used to thinking of
where you have ideas that come from
Christianity you apply the human mind to
make sense of them you explore them the
first a lot of us we know but now you're
starting to say yes actually the
distinction between philosophy and
theology isn't so so rigid as in the
early 20th century a lot of things that
we were calling philosophy nowadays
eventually called theology Juan del was
actually seen as a fundamental
theologian as well as a philosopher Joe
saw more attend but as much as they
really resisted the idea being
theologians a lot of what they're doing
kind of seems now Maurice Bloom down is
another guy and actually we're going to
take a break in just a minute I just why
I introduced you to just a few things
and then we're going to talk about
lawndale's philosophies for the rest of
the session blown-down was very critical
of everyone involved in this debate he
was critical of the rationalists of the
Neel scholastics why because they put
this rigid division between faith and
reason and once you actually do that the
game is over
if you define things that way then you
can't come to a conception of Christian
philosophy where these
in some sort of relation to each other
if you start out with that assumption
and it's an assumption putting out if
you start out with that assumption that
these are closed off spheres you're done
well what about going to jail song and
Maura temple what about saying well you
know Christianity contributes these
ideas and then philosophy just sort of
takes them in and makes it their own and
runs with it is that okay
luenell says that by itself there's a
little bit of confusion there's some
dangers in doing that your philosophy
becomes less strictly philosophical
unless you do certain things and that's
where I'm gonna leave you for right now
we'll take a 5-10 minute break and then
we'll come back we'll talk about this
notion of an open philosophy and
philosophy of insufficiency and we'll
talk about where we're really going with
this the problem of the supernatural so
and if you have any questions for me
during the break you can come up and ask
me individually I'm gonna get that
website up for you too okay